Speaker 1: As you might have heard,
there are people peacefully protesting
at the Supreme Court. Now, when I use the term
peacefully protesting, I actually mean it. I'm
not referring to the Trump riots of January 6th,
which were extraordinarily violent and criminal,
and saying it was a peaceful protest. I'm actually
talking about just peaceful protest, protected
by the First Amendment with permits, even permits
for the speech. And yesterday, Florida Republican
Governor Ron DeSantis was in New York, and
he said that those protesters at the Supreme
Court are engaging in an insurrection. And this is
something we've seen many times from Republicans.
When they do a thing, they start saying it is
the left who is actually doing that thing. When
a word starts to be part of the middle, you they
start to use the word and try to redefine it
or change it. Which is funny because it's
what they accused the left of doing. Oh,
the left is trying to redefine woman. The left is
trying to read this. Right. But now you're saying
that just a protest is an insurrection because you
don't like the fact that your side did a horrible,
riotous insurrection attempt on January 6th of
2021. So let's look at what Ron DeSantis said,
not sounding, I will say, like the biggest
supporter of the First Amendment here.
Speaker 4: What they're trying to bring is
attention to the fact that the Supreme Court may
overturn Roe v Wade later today or then again,
the coverage could come out next week when they
ultimately do issue their opinion.
Speaker 6: Well, I think that we have
a rule of law in this country, and you
don't get to just have a mob descend on
a Supreme Court justices house or try
to impede the operations of government
because there may be a decision you don't like
that would be considered an insurrection to
stop a court from functioning. And yet they
seem to be able to get away with a lot more
than if the shoe were on the other foot. So. Okay.
Speaker 1: So, listen, we have to break these
things down one by one. First and foremost,
the armed person who went to Kavanaugh's house,
absolutely outrageous, seemingly criminal. Arrest
them, charge them, throw the book at him 100%
in terms of the protests in general, at the
judges, at the justices houses. I've already
said it is for law enforcement and the Justice
Department to figure out when is it legal and
when is it not. There are elements of that
that are absolutely protected by free speech,
and there are elements of it that may go over.
And it has to do with the specifics of where the
protest is taking place, etc.. But the protesters
at the Supreme Court are not trying to shut down
the Supreme Court. They are making their voices
heard. And it is a permitted, peaceful protests,
a real permitted peaceful protest, unlike
what happened on January 6th. And think of
the absurdity, right? I mean, on the one hand,
they want us to believe January 6th was fine,
despite the fact that there
were there was violence,
there were people entering the building. There
were people chanting to hang the vice president.
There were people stealing stuff. There were
people breaking windows. That was nothing.
That was fine. It was peaceful. It was tourists.
It was whatever. On the other hand, the current
Supreme Court protests, no violence. They have
permits. They're not entering the building.
They're not chanting to hang anyone. They're
not stealing stuff. They're not breaking windows
that we're supposed to believe is an insurrection.
And of course, hopefully the interviewer would
point that out and ask a follow up question. But
at the end of the day, it is Fox News, by the way,
there they haven't even built gallows to hang
anyone at the Supreme Court protests, which is an
interesting, notable thing. So the real concern
here is, I mean, listen, DeSantis is a clown,
but the real concern is if these people get power
back in November in the House and or Senate, which
they may if DeSantis becomes the next president,
I mean, I know it's early, but he's doing really
well in 2024 primary polling, and he's not even
running and he's less incompetent than Trump. It's
not inconceivable that he could become president
if these people get power and they may get it
back soon. What does it actually mean for peace,
for real peaceful protest? What does it mean for
criticism of the government or whatever the case
may be? Extraordinarily scary and dystopian stuff